this is 14 Part B putts to find the
center of a circle now a couple of
things happen here right um some of you
tried it but um maybe you got your full
Chiron well I'm surprised by how many
people said the focus of that ellipse
was the origin it's like wow we really
really okay
so then obviously that's screwed over
later uh you got your the parabola had a
focus of all I think was an eight an
eight is urine or is it zero net journey
Elara and um that was easy that was just
one mark unless of course you forgot
that when you're putting the equation of
a parabola in parametric so no
prescription point um in a form that
makes the the focal length and the
directrix obvious right you forgot that
this was the form right so many of you
thought this is the floor and so you've
got the wrong value for a which means
you've got the wrong value for the focus
which means you couldn't find the center
because the numbers just died on you
okay so basic stuff people basic stuff
right now once you've got that that's
for the parabola the ellipse believe not
did have to okay like most ellipses do I
think it was up I was a possum eyes with
a root five on six wasn't it okay they
go now all right put your pens down and
look up for a second okay because so far
I've been picking our questions that
most of you have had trouble with or a
large number here's what none of you did
nothing
not one drew a diagram not one eye now
you get sick of it really I couldn't see
it it was that bad oh my yeah chaos
optimum now if you didn't draw a diagram
how did you expect to get the answer
right
no wonder early tree if you got it right
so when you look at this thing right you
got your zero on it so it's up here
okay then you've got your plus or minus
three or five or six which are both
there so then you've got your circle
coming through like that
so immediately on drawing the diagram
you can see that your Center is going to
be somewhere on the y-axis right call it
anything you like call it 0k or
something like that or minus K now
you've hired your work because you're
like where's the center we'll only need
to worry about one number you'll need to
worry about that part and then all you
had to write was um even the people who
got this right probably spent too much
time on it all you have to say was look
I've got two radii here right this
radius and this radius are equal
okay now look at that that's just up and
down right that's easy to work out you
know your distance formula for that it's
very very simple numbers okay so
therefore what you end up getting if you
call that negative K which I do
what's this length here right well
what's that length if I call that
negative K what's that mean it's K and
what's this thing remember the corner
it's just an eighth right so this here
is K plus 1/8 that's it right and then
there's a distance formula here but all
you're interested in is the x-value
right so you get this k plus 1/8 is
equal to what my god square root of this
guy because it's just Pythagoras really
when you're doing one of the values
there you go and the quadrat you get at
the end isn't that bad I know the number
you end up with is not very pretty okay
but it only took three four lines it's
just these fractures that you have to
deal with and that was not where most of
you guys have troubled most of you guys
had trouble because you never visualized
it so you didn't realize how easily you
could frame the problem and how simply
you could get the marks of it okay